you asked why I want divorce to be
banned yeah can I finish yeah first so
I'm saying you know the people that
believe in divorce go be in long-term
relationships leave marriage for the
people that actually believe in For
Better or For Worse for richer for
poorer in sickness and in health till
death do us part doesn't the sanctity of
marriage also rely on the woman being a
virgin so you wouldn't be able to get
married I what do you what do you mean
well you've spoken quite openly about
how you're not a virgin and so if you
want to preserve that sanctity of
marriage
I just think that you're upholding
standards that you don't know you know
and that's a fair that's a fair
complaint I wish I was but you know we
can't go back I don't know what you want
me to say but I just don't think earlier
that you get to be here and you get to
be paid for your views and you're
telling other women that they shouldn't
be allowed